at a record. Welcome again to another Zoom call and let's jump right into the questions.
Just another reminder. Please send your questions via the member site. We cannot answer any
emailed questions. This is the law has changed since COVID and they're just really the American Medical
Association and all the medical boards are just clamping down on one one visits with practitioners
that are licensed in that particular state. I can go over labs because I'm not really giving it
any medical advice that's not really a medical visit. But I can't answer questions so we got to
keep it to a Zoom call like this. It's just it's crazy and it is the law. Dr. Ricola had a big
thing that came out today. How the American Medical Association and the FDA and everybody has
tried to shut down his site. Google has already you know shadow banned him so with us you go directly
to his site. It's really hard to get to him. Joe Tippen's site has been completely shadow banned
by Google. If you know his website you can actually go to his website to learn more about the
Joe Tippen's protocol. But you search Fendizal and Joe Tippen's on Google and you just won't
find anything anymore. The FDA has made us take all our Fendizal and Joe Tippen's information off
of our site and off of the store. This is the reality of what's going on in the alternative
perspective and in the realm of our world. We're getting attacked literally on a weekly basis
by the pharmaceutical industry. Like I've never seen throughout all my years of practice. They are
using this pandemic to literally try to destroy anybody that's not doing pharmaceutical and following
the pharmaceutical protocols. So just so you know Dr. I'm writing but this is why we have to do these
Zoom calls. Zoom calls are educational it's still free speech at least for the time being. So
being able to educate in a group like this is still free speech. So ask all the questions you need
to ask in these Zoom calls. I do please just to help me save my voice. Please do glean through past
Zoom calls. If you have time you might be able to download them on your phone and you could just
listen to them like a podcast. We're trying to figure out ways to better have access to things like
that as well so that to give you access to that. But because I get you know you're new to our clinic
you don't have time to listen to you know 500 Zoom calls give me a break I get that I really do
but please just try to look at some of the things on the member site and some of the things on our
website when you're asking questions because the questions might already be answered that just
saves you too. So all right member members as our full members are quote unquote patients you have
full access to all my courses and I'm going to have an autoimmune course and a mushroom course soon
so you have access to all of these use the same username and same password as you do to get out of the
member site. You could jump on those courses if you really want to do it out and some stuff. Certainly
you can learn more about your genetics. We have some genetics questions in today's Zoom call.
Go to the Read Your Genes course right here and you can learn all about your genetics and more
than you really would ever care to know. So and then the healing frequency healing course has a lot
of information more information about the right to questions. What is the difference between
tumor cells and cancer cells? Is there a difference? You've touched on this many many Zoom calls.
There really is no difference. It's old terminology. What's a tumor? What's a cancerous tumor?
What's just cancer? How's there a difference? It's hard when there's been decades and decades and
decades of medicine and terminology used in the practice of medicine and updated terminology
is still as used but then the old terminology is used everywhere. It's interchangeable. So
or is it tumor benign or is it is it malignant? Well depends on what adjective you put in front of it.
So when you say cancer then you always know that's a malignant disease. If you say tumor then
you have to know what adjective you put in front of it. Is it a malignant tumor? Is it benign tumor?
It's semantics. People who say stay away from animal protein can they use collagen?
Maybe, maybe not. So we test for that if we think the person should be able to use collagen or not.
If you're a hardcore vegan then you're not taking collagen but if you're only staying away from
animal protein because you have cancer and animal protein can feed the cancer then typically not.
You could you you could use collagen but if you're you're staying away from animal protein for some
you know you know moral ethical reason then you would probably stay away from collagen as well.
But with a cancer no you're probably safe with collagen. Can he used with a castor oil pass
cause constipation? No I don't think so. No I mean anything could cause anything I guess but
pretty much probably not. Can castor oil pack be used on low p breasts? I don't know if you're
just talking about fibrosistic breast disease using a castor oil pack. I don't know when you put
castor oil on your skin you will absorb some of it. I don't think I would do castor oil packs on
fibrosistic breast. No I wouldn't do that. I certainly wouldn't do it over a breast tumor as well.
Damn metabolize I think this means can't will damn metabolize good astrogens or just bad
astrogens. It can metabolize both. I don't think it's specific just to the four hydroxy
esteroids. I think it can help get rid of all astrogens which isn't a bad thing because other
astrogens are precursor tune for hydroxy esteroids. So I think it will reduce all of it. Again,
not anything like taking a medical drug or rheumatoid inhibitor but it certainly will reduce
the total astrogens. I found a local physician willing to provide IV vitamin C infusions.
We will begin after I can provide them with a dosing and frequency.
Can you throw out suggestions so I can get started? Well, the physician who's giving you the IV
infusions should be making this suggestion. I will make you a suggestion but they're the ones that
are that they should be the dosing doctors. I will tell you that most clinics that you go to for
IV vitamin C want to get you up to high doses very quickly. I think it's best to titrate
meeting that you started a lower dose and you go up. Now, what dose do you start it? Something like
20 grams and then over the course of a month maybe you're getting up to 60, 80 grams. That is
also depends on how many times a week you're doing it. If you're just doing it once a week it might
take you two months to get up to 80 grams or 75 grams. A lot of clinics jump on 50 grams right away
and get you up to 100 grams. It can have some side effects too so I don't know that personally,
I would do that. I would start at 20 grams, do that multiple times and move up to 40 grams.
It also depends on the bags that they're supplier that they're getting them from and what
increment, gram, increment that they can raise that at. I always think it's better to start
slower and move up. Can you please explain what some of this means? This person said in
information on their RGCC test. Everybody know what the RGCC test is. The RGCC test, they have
multiple different things that you can run with RGCC. It's also known as the Greek test.
That tests different genetic, specific genetic markers that would be specific to different tumors
and it can be built as a cancer test that can predict cancer in a person. I think I have cancer
but I don't know so I can run the RGCC test and run this particular test with RGCC which this person
ran and they might get some inkling whether they have cancer or not. I certainly hope
that the doctor that ordered, I don't order the RGCC test. We don't do the RGCC test.
I hope the doctor that ordered this test did it tell you or if you have ever done it that you've
never had a doctor tell you that we'll do this RGCC test and this will tell you if you have cancer
or not. Because the only thing that can tell you if you have cancer or not from a medical legal
standpoint is a biopsy. Nothing else can tell you from a medical legal standpoint. It could give you
clues but it can't tell you specifically. You have paid credit cancer. You have liver cancer.
You have this cancer. Now certainly scans, like a CT scan especially on a PET scan even more so
at an MRI can a radiologist who's a good radiologist who's looked at 50,000 slides can look at it and
go to that's cancer but then they even write it in a port that says this is suggestive at astrosyptoma
or this is suggestive colorectal adenocarcinoma but they can't legally say that it is because the
only way that you can say that it is cancer is through a biopsy. The radiologist has looked at these
scans a million times and they could they know that they had no carcinoma but they can't legally
say that that's why you see that type of verbiage called a CT scan but they say it's suggestive of
it's you know they give you that type of protective terminology so that they're suggesting that
this is a progression of the cancer or this is a the test is this to the bone but without a biopsy
I can't be for sure. So with the RGCC test it's the same thing they can say this is suggestive of this
type of cancer but they can't say that it's cancer nor they can they be specific that it is
the exact cancer that you're looking for. This uh the rest of this question I think was a comment
from the doctor who ran the test it said this test was supposed to tell me or this this
artist with the patient this test was supposed to tell me the exact tissue the cancer is coming from
so if you if you thought that and you were told by the ordinary doctor that was incorrect maybe they
didn't say that and maybe that's what you heard maybe they didn't say that and that was misinformation.
Can you help me understand this for example what is TN and TTN morbid and what does it likely
path what does likely pathogenic mean um I can I don't interpret that RGCC test so if you guys
go through the RGCC test through another practitioner you need to have that other practitioner
interpret it for you because that's not my specialty I don't run that test I have a done intensive
study on that test and I don't plan to because that's not my specialty so you have to have them interpret
TTN morbid I don't know what that means that's a terminology specifically from RGCC
but likely pathogenic this term right here so they say this is likely pathogenic that is
another one of those terms that like a radiologist would say this is suggestive um you know
likely pathogenic means this is probably cancer but I can't say that because legally you would have
to do a biopsy to say that so unfortunately I had multiple people come to me and say I did the
RGCC test because the practitioner said that's what's going to diagnose the cancer and I have said
okay you got to understand that does not diagnose cancer you know legally the only diagnosis of
cancer that you could get is through biopsy so um I hope practitioners that run these tests aren't
giving misinformation um because they're not an expensive test to run um and if they're leaving
people with the same doubt then that they had before they had the test that I questioned the value
this is the same thing I say you know with every test that you do you have to weigh it out between okay
is this going to give me information that's going to help me change the way I treat my body
and if the answer is no because I'm going to keep treating the same way then why do the test
if the answer is yeah then then do the test what makes me a little sad is that if a practitioner told
you that it wasn't going to get you information then it and it fell short of that I feel bad
for the person who ran that test so I apologize and I can't give you any more information on that
that if you do call the office and say I want Dr. Cutters to go over my RGCC test
Marie or whoever answers is going to say no he doesn't do that because I don't do that I don't want
to do something that I don't feel qualified to give you that information and it's not going to help you
I want to stay within my lead in my knowledge center and
which is pretty limited I don't but that's not something I specialize in I don't want to
I don't want to box couple of records so kind of ties into this question what's your opinion on
SOT therapy well I don't know a lot about SOT therapy but what's same thing that you could read about
it because it's not something I do I've had multiple we've had multiple members do it
um but they were doing a whole bunch of other stats um so you know they you know the one that I
talked to this was about a year and a half ago they said oh they thought it helped but there was
no objective data that it helped so um you know even they said that you know so I think there's
validity in all these different types of therapies um but um yeah I just I just don't know enough
about it to say yeah I think it's great or I don't think it's great um I know there's place in the
plate now there remember when to a place out in Florida that did it but I know there's places
that they're doing too I just did a parasite test kit when the batting system seems to get
backed up when detoxing just doing my normal protocol for cancer what is your thoughts on doing a
parasite cleanse if they determine I have them I feel like I don't feel good more than I feel good
especially with swollen lymph in my neck and sore throat so so this is so we talk about parasites
um it gets a little tricky because most most functional medicine doctors and certainly all
regular medical doctors if they see a parasite test they think oh my gosh we got to kill them
you know there's parasites well why not they're not horrible we got to kill those parasites
but there's a whole other light of thinking so um oh yes access parasites in your body can cause
um issues where your immune system is fighting a battle at multiple fields and in one sense it does
make sense to kill parasites but in another sense you have to understand that even parasites can have
a symbiotic relationship in your body um meeting that they aren't necessarily doing damage all the time
um and if you're going to try to do a big parasite cleanse and flush using
things like wormwood and olive leaf extract and different herbal things like that well those
are good and that can be great um you you have to look at am I healthy enough to do that is it
is it going to be poor or con to me the best thing to do honestly I know this isn't the great
you know yes or no answer but the best thing to do is you can try things so there are some parasite
protocols with biocided and cell core products that you could use to you know you could even
pulse them instead of doing a like I'm going to do this 21 day parasite cleanse you could go I'm
going to do you know maybe every other day with this or I'm going to do every third day with this
and see if it makes you worse let me take a step back many people with cancer you know you're
solely focused on the cancer but we ignore sometimes um uh the possibility in the real
likeness that we also have comorbidities but we also have other things going on and the most
common thing that we have going on that we see throughout society is a comorbidity of an autoimmune
disease you have an autoimmune um secondary baby even primary to the cancer um condition going on
you have antibodies to self tissue that's why by autoimmune course I really want let's I get done
everybody you know all my cancer members to go through it because it they're you're going to find
that there's a lot of ties that um tie in with cancer in autoimmune disorders um so
what is an autoimmune disorder it's when you have antibodies to self tissue any self tissue
that you have antibodies to and then there's different levels of autoimmune disorders it could be in a
latent um level where it's not really causing symptoms to um you know a tissue destructive level where
you see you know damage to bolder you have damage to the tissue itself um and then the middle level is
where you have the symptoms but not a huge amount of tissue destruction a lot of people are in
that second level where you have symptoms of that and many times we are blaming cancer for some
of the symptoms that we may be experiencing that are really autoimmune related the reason I'm talking
about it with the question about parasites is that when you have an autoimmune issue and you're going
to go after killing a parasite that can flare an autoimmune issue so um typically trying to kill a
parasite um with some of the the nutritional things that I talked about a couple of minutes ago
if you solely have cancer there's really no harm no fault it's not gonna hurt your cancer
by using some of those parasite killing parasite cleansing nutrients or even a parasite killing
medication it could actually help the count kill the cancer um in the case of like iverbectated
fan bed is all and things like that but if you have an autoimmune disease cold morbidity
then you could actually flare that and become worse that's why I said even if your parasite test comes
back positive I would still maybe go slow with the treatment because if you have a cold morbid
autoimmune disorder you could get worse um that effect some autoimmune patients do better
when they have a parasite which is a total flipflop of understanding there is actually a treatment
for autoimmune disease that's called uh um health synth treatment where you actually get a bottle of
these parasite eggs and you take that once a week yeah crazy so you're actually inoculating
yourself the parasites and in doing so it causes an immune reaction in the gut and it takes the
immune reaction away from um the autoimmune site let's say if it's thyroid or if it's a
lupus or ms um and it's really has helped a lot of ms patients so don't take it too off on that subject
video we got to you got to you know keep it balanced that you know just because I have this doesn't
need I have to kill it there could be negatives to it as well I hope they did take to the answer to
the question but one day there's a question about swollen lip builds I have breast cancer and the
nodes under my arm are very sore is dmso something to use to bring relief or is there something else
that could help like I said dmso dyself that oxide is a sulfur component you could buy dmso it's liquid
it's like water um uh and um you just use a little bit on a cotton swab and um it's highly anti-inflammatory
now it's a sulfur component so you'll taste garlic in your mouth after putting it on your skin
but it was very common in the 70s and 80s to use it on your um I like a swollen knee or a sore ankle
or rheumatoid arthritis any type of joydarts rightus and it kind of fell out of sorts because the
FDA went after an all and said it was a hoax and all this kind of stuff but it isn't anti-inflammatory
you can't argue with it but it is also readily absorbed through the skin and it can be a driver so if
you have lotion on your skin that's toxic and you put dmso on it it'll drive the toxic lotion right
into your body you shouldn't be putting toxic lotion on your skin it's the lesson but um so you've
got to be careful with it if you have dirt on your skin or if you have you know gasoline on your skin
and you put dmso on your literally driving the gasoline and it's toxin uh petroleum toxins right
into your bloodstream so you have to be careful what you use it over but if you have clean skin
putting a cotton using a clean organic cotton swab in the bottle of dmso and putting it right on it
test it see how it works it could be a great anti-inflammatory you could also use it to drive other
things so you could get a liquid zinc put that on the skin and then put dmso over it just like that
if you're putting a putting them that's why the some of the blood root pastes have dmso on it
because it will drive the blood root in through the skin so you can use it as a driver of other things too
I have had body lots of body aches possibly long coma that have been on predisone
is there something else I could use I had been using the clear inflame but that just wasn't in
earth make sure you're running the covid programs on the rife machine so i do have a video on the
website about long covid as well um i'll try to tomorrow we'll try to remember to put it up on the
member site um it might be better on the member site so the FDA doesn't come after me
about that video too um and that will help too nothing is going to decrease inflammation as fast as
predisone i'll tell you that um so the other thing that you could use for that has helped a lot of
people is a product called limitless limitless is a betaline it's a patented betaline product
which is the most highly anti-inflammatory substance that you can get without a medic without a
prescription it's called limitless it comes in a box of 20 or 30 of or something like that we have
another store limitless that might help as well uh we've seen people that were uh i have i haven't
personally seen anybody at predisone but i've seen people that taking 20 tyledol a day go and
limitless and go on can offer if they're admiral entitlement after retesting a cheek swab at
august we changed a few supplements one of my new ones is clear deal the first time i started it
by only took it for a week i had nausea hot flashes and genital yeast issues
interesting we've had i mean it's the same person making these comments i don't know but um
multiple comments of people using dim and getting these type of symptoms one of these type of symptoms
they're symptoms of dropping estrogen levels so nausea hot flashes genital yeast issues
urinary tract infection type things that is a symptom of lowered estrogen that's the goal of dim
so you're purposely taking it to lower your estrogen levels so you could back off on your doses to help
help with that issue you can pulse it to help with that issue but in reality that's really what we're
trying to accomplish with it i recently started again week or two ago and i'm not having the hot flashes
or nausea but i'm having reflux and yeast issues again i would suggest the reflux has nothing to do with it
the yeast yes it probably has to do with it as well as joint pains in my hip and figures
yes that could have to do with lowered estrogen levels so i would just pulse it
even if you take it every other day if you take it um you know for three days off for three days
that's called pulsing or supplement something like that that you feel comfortable with
should i continue the clear yep so i would continue to do that one more question related to
hormones one of my cancer causes was hormones according to the testing i was
taking bioidentical progesterone before by diagnosis but have not since March of last year
would you recommend progestines uh essential oil that's a young living oil or progesterone
cream or is it best to stay away from these with my breast cancer history i would not recommend those
things i would highly recommend you stay away from those things well why i have an estrogen positive
cancer not progesterone positive cancer because pro excess progesterone so you're taking this
cream you're taking progesterone progestants which has estrogen in it too that's a topical
essential oil as well you're getting progesterone absorbed through the skin and absorbs very readily
you're increasing the progesterone in your body that's what i would recommend if i want to increase
somebody's progesterone um which i used to use that a lot for different patients um
thousands wheelies really seek cancer patients we use that less because if you have an estrogen
progesterone or her two positive cancer or even if you don't have that you can
um you will increase your estrogen oh no this is progesterone not estrogen excess progesterone
is going to be stored in your fat cells so excess hormones progesterone testosterone and estrogen
gets stored in your fat cells and then you have a enzyme called enromatase that breaks down that
hormone in your fat cells to the bad estrogens um which you don't want to do so you should not
you know this is where women should not take testosterone either if they have a horrible driven
cancer um because excess testosterone will be stored in the fat cells and roba taste will break it out
into bad estrogen hence the term odorobotase inhibitor and aerobotase inhibitor
blocks the breakdown of bad uh of any hormones into bad estrogens it helps eliminate
all estrogens from your body that's what an aerobotase inhibitor does it's blocking that whole pathway
so that is a normal pathway in your body excess progesterone will be stored in fat cells and
aerobotase in two bad estrogens you don't let that happen so no you don't take that i was listening to
a podcast and he mentioned that high d h e a was a risk factor for breast kit why would that be
because d h e a is a formal and d h e a is a precursor to pro to testosterone and progesterone
so that's why it is a risk factor for breast cancer when it's but it's elevated that's why i don't
recommend people take d h e a so it's very common that's a supplement you could get that you know
anywhere and it's very common to take d h e a and have um doctors who recommend d h e a especially
when people have a adrenal fatigue so oh you have a adrenal fatigue just take d h e a that will
really help well it really well but it's good it's a precursor to progesterone and testosterone which
then is a precursor to for hydroxyestero which can increase your risk the breast cancer i had a
Dutch test almost two years ago and they noted in my report that my d h e a was within range
but higher than expected for my age is there anything i should cross reference in my genetics
results on that issue or any other results in the Dutch test that could give me more clues
about what caused or fuels my cancer nothing in the genetics will show the correlation with d h e a
doing another Dutch test can be beneficial so it depends you did the Dutch test two years ago
you should probably do it again you can order it at our store so we send you the kit you do it at home
you set it in and we talk about the results doing another Dutch test would be the thing to do
and we do the Dutch i think it's called the Dutch complete which also gives you a whole adrenal profile
um and measures your d h e a too soon when we get additional supplements recommended with our genetic
report are those correlated with the previous cheek swab recommendations uh so i was given
pun what assist at a i after the genetics no that's totally based upon your genetics and okay so let's
finish question because i remember you say that just because you have a problem with the g doesn't
mean it's affecting the cancer like i have a couple other variants that can elevate whole
cystine and blood pressure but i have neither symptom i'm just trying to prioritize expenses i'm assuming
that the first recommendations are enough to cover what seems to be relevant genetic information but i
don't know how to tell which ones are affecting my cancer the most so i would agree if you you know
if finances are an issue and you want to drop supplements i dropped the genetic ones first um
your pun the pun what assist or what we have privately labeled as phase two is really supporting
your phase two pathways that is really i tell you talk about correlative and i don't know
causative fact but um the pun one pathway with breast cancer is just like amazing um there's actually
a lot of research that's coming out about pun love defects with breast cancer and it's just correlative
but it's you know it's not necessarily caused causative but it's a huge correlation so i would drop
to a i i would keep the pun love assist if you can the description to the side uh for the a i supplement
seems off was it reformulated no it wasn't it doesn't describe the terrible the terrible is the
is the bentonite clay um it says it has glycine which i could use
for what a yg variance but the label ingredients does not have glycine it i'll have to look at that
that a i is actually a supplement that i personally formulated for php so i'll have to plot
the supplement and see get whoever that was few years ago in the next one
from the chat just getting up and running and didn't get a question in early or have the
opportunity to search prior to today sorry that's okay we don't i don't have some of the programs i
wish to run on the right say they need a bulb um like the hammer bulb other than the hammer bulb um
okay so just ignore them so you have a hammer bulb is the qx2 bulb a better bulb no is the qx2 bulb
stronger if you put it right up to your skin yes is the qx2 bulb for the purpose of putting
it right up next to your skin no the qx2 bulb is for putting it on a stand to use during the day
so you can walk around the house and it will go out a little bit farther and you'll get a little bit
more benefit um do you need the qx2 bulb no do i even recommend the qx2 bulb almost number now they
have the hammer the jackhammer if you want to use it during the day and you want to walk around but
still it's only gonna really go out eight ten feet so do i suggest you even get that no if you call
true right are they gonna try to sell you all these things probably so personally i only use the hammer
bulb so just that's what i would suggest unless you're gonna like do some of the facial programs and you
want to get that a zinger bulb that is a that is a bulb you're putting like some some different
nutrients on your skin and you're using the bulb on your if you're doing a specific purpose like that
then yeah you could get that zinger bulb um but only that i wouldn't use anything but the hammer bulb
personally um that's and you could ignore just because they have a different bulb in the picture
doesn't need anything um and just because they have it in the right up it's just that's what they were
using when it was written up so don't worry about that seems like taking honey and pure maple syrup has
dealt well for me should i not use stevia as well or are they not even closely related
so honey maple syrup and stevia are typically used to sweeten food um they're all natural
um but two of them are gonna increase glucose levels
so if i was on a pure ketogenic diet you would i could not take honey and maple syrup i would use stevia
as a sweetener um but if you know so if you're trying to keep your glucose levels down you try to use
more stevia um is there benefits to honey yes there's other possible benefits to honey is there
benefits to maple syrup you know that really but it is a sweetener and both honey and maple syrup do
i think they're kind of the middle um the uh range of how fast they break down to glucose um stevia
won't elevate your glucose so sorry not taking honey or maple syrup okay well certainly stevia
is going to be safer for not you know increasing your glucose levels can the right program be installed
on a back lap time yes but you have it's a different program it's a program for back um we got a second
right and was going to put on my laptop for convenience um uh when the uh hp is upstairs
you can put it under your back you have to download after them true right and um they do have
not download for back so it looks different you're gonna have to get used to it personally
i have it on my back um i don't use it on my back i don't like the way it looks it's just it's just
odd for me because i've used it for 15 years i'm a PC and i don't use a PC for anything but the right
by only use Mac for computer stuff and so is pod what assists very different from alijic acid no it's not
so if you're already taking alijic acid you really don't need pod what assists so uh alijic acid actually
has if you're taking the alijic caps all agic aps from best-out-earth products if that's what
you're taking okay yes then you don't need uh then you don't need the pod what assists because that
has enough pod of credit at it um i have a bottle right here i actually take that too that's a good
product um so you don't need the problem it's a good question pod of a credit is so good for us if
you like to eat some don't talk about that a lot because you know some that commonly used and we
think of berries and raspberries because we grow raspberries blueberries and strawberries you don't
you readily think of pod of credits with pod of credits going remember um good idea to coursework
for uh functional cardiology um that uh taking i think it was literally like a quarter cup of
pod of credits a day lowered a person's blood pressure as well as 20 milligrams of lucidipro
that's crazy so um it's really good for your heart pod of credit is one of the best things for your
heart at your blood pressure and it's really good for your face to pathway in your liver so really
good for detoxification pod of credits are great now it does have glucose and it will raise your glucose
levels but it's one of those really good foods so getting promegranates and blending those into your
smoothie um would be another great thing you instead of just using blackberries blueberries
and raspberries so great nutrients always great nutrients that don't give us
natural ways all right i think we will call it a night thank you guys for being on again tonight
know that i'll be praying for all you and i'm all of you guys and i'm not praying for you guys
not kidding every single night um i ask that you keep praying for our protection
that our health as well and uh get your questions in uh the member site and i'll see you in Monday bye bye